ارتداء حزام الامان اثناء القياده اجباري
ومن الضروري ان يربط كافه الركاب حزام
الامان في السياره مخالفه ذلك تفرض على
صاحبها غرامه قد تصل الى 500 جنيه
بعد ظهور رئيس الوزراء في فيديو لا يرتدي
فيه حزام الامان فيما سيارته تتحرك سوناك
اعتذر عن خلع الحزام الامان خلال التصويره
مقطع لمتابعه على الانستغرام واعتبره خطا
في التقدير سونار قد يتلقى غرامه ماليه
على هذه المخالفه الجديده بعد تغريمه 50
جنيه العام الماضي لخلقه قواعد كورونا
عندما كان وزير الماليه في عهد حكومه برج
الجونسون
لا تشرع قانون
في حالي ثبتت التهمه سيتلقى ريشي سوناك
الثانيه غرامه الله بعد مخالفته القانون
مرتين في الحكومه البريطانيه الا اذا وجدت
الشرطه التبريرا المقنعا لعدم ارتداء حزام
الامان وذلك في الحالات الاستثنائيه
الصحيه المحدوده وهذا مستبعد في حاله
سوناك لا احد يستخفه بالتحديات التي
تواجهه بريطانيا من اقتصاد المتعثر وغلاء
ان نعيشه واضرابات تتسع عدتها والان ريش
هناك الذي يقود البلاد في هذه المرحله
الحرجه في ازمه خاصه بسبب خلقه القانونه
خلال اداء مهامه وان لم تكن تابعتها واضحه
بعد
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن